this is the camp wildfire on November 8
2018 the fire tore across a rural
section of Northern California it was
the deadliest and most destructive fire
in California history that consumed the
town of paradise in a matter of hours
forcing its residents to flee and panic
an investigation found that the camp
fire was caused by a line owned by
Pacific Gas & Electric or PG&E it was
the latest in a string of fires that
ultimately led the state's largest
utility company to file for bankruptcy
but with this bankruptcy it isn't just
shareholders and creditors who have an
interest in the future of the company
millions of Californians rely on the
utility to keep the lights on and some
are questioning whether PG&E can be
trusted to do that safely and reliably
that's because according to documents
reviewed by The Wall Street Journal the
company knew for years its equipment had
the potential to start fires yet
repeatedly delayed the necessary
upgrades to make some of its lines safer
this is the story of how PG&E filed for
bankruptcy
in 1905 newly incorporated Pacific Gas
and Electric was competing with other
utilities to electrify Northern
California with power generated high in
the Sierra Nevada a vision of a regional
power system was something that really
hadn't been tried in too many other
places around the world the predecessors
to PG&E built a series of dams then
built long high-voltage transmission
lines across the Central Valley to San
Francisco PG&E emerged really through
consolidation of a number of companies
to serve more and more parts of Northern
California with increasing demands for
energy but safety and reliability issues
have plagued the utilities since the 90s
in 1996 PG&E settled a multi-million
dollar lawsuit alleging a tainted
drinking water around Hinkley California
in 2001 the California energy crisis
resulted in rolling blackouts and drove
the corporation's utility arm to file
for bankruptcy and in 2010 a PG&E gas
pipeline exploded in San Bruno
California killing eight people PG&E was
placed on federal probation as a result
of the explosion to ensure the utility
operated safely in the communities it
served in many of those Northern
California communities were growing in
rural areas a lot of the residential
construction that's occurred over the
last several decades has been in what we
would call the wildland urban interface
the fringe of the built environment
putting people out into the forest since
that time hasn't been a lot of new
construction of the backbone system many
of the utilities transmission towers
were constructed in the first half of
the 20th century outside of Paradise is
a high voltage transmission line owned
by PG&E the 56 mile line known as the
caribou Palermo was built in 1921 its
towers and lines tap into a
hydroelectric system known as the
stairway of power
PG&E estimated the mean life expectancy
of its high-voltage transmission towers
was 65 years old but the company
estimated the average age of all the
towers still in service was 68
the oldest towers in the system were 108
years old equipment like these high
voltage and low voltage lines does fail
but the failure is is is low consequence
so you have an older transmission line
that was nearing the end of its service
life and something would break during a
big winter storm in the Sierra and when
the storm ended tge crews could go out
and fix the line what's changed is when
the power lines fail in California and
the consequences of a failure from 2013
to 2019 a historic drought swept across
California killing millions of trees and
greatly increasing the risk of fire
according to a PG&E List obtained by The
Wall Street Journal the caribou Palermo
was one of the grids worst performing
circuits it also ran through areas that
were identified as posing elevated and
extreme fire risks in 2017 PG&E
equipment started 18 fires that killed
22 people according to state fire
officials according to an internal
presentation from that same year the
company said it needed a plan to replace
its steel structure transmission towers
and better manage its equipment to
prevent it from causing fires
on the morning of November 8th 2018
winds picked up before sunrise in your
paradise a hook connecting a power line
to a caribou Palermo tower failed
causing the line to strike the tower and
emit sparks that fell to the ground a
few minutes later a PG&E worker spotted
a small fire near the tower that fire
grew quickly by 8 a.m. local officials
had given the order to evacuate by 10:45
the fire had overtaken parts of the
paradise trying to get out of paradise
this is bad oh my god 10 is bad
[Music]
by 6:00 p.m. the fire had completely
consumed the town in the aftermath the
local sheriff's office said bodies were
found in vehicles most likely of people
who are trying to escape the fire
anthropologists and forensic dentists
were tasked with identifying human
remains that sometimes consisted only of
a few bone fragments or teeth for PG&E
the destruction caused by the campfire
was an existential threat utility faced
thousands of wildfire claims seeking
damages for amongst other things
wrongful death personal injury and
property damage from October 2018 to
January 2019 PG and E's market value
slid from about 25 billion dollars to 9
billion by declaring bankruptcy the
utility strategy was to fold these
claims into a bankruptcy proceeding
allowing the company to negotiate
settlements with all of its creditors
including the fire victims a Wall Street
Journal investigation revealed the
company knew that 57 of the steel towers
on the Cariboo Palermo line needed
Hardware replaced and another 49 towers
needed to be replaced entirely before
the camp fire in 2013 PG&E told federal
regulators it had a 30 million dollar
plan to replace equipment on the Cariboo
Palermo line but it repeatedly delayed
the project for five years it was slated
to begin as late as June 2018 but it
didn't happen the utility released a
statement in response to the journals
reporting saying the scheduled work
wasn't maintenance related and at the
tower that malfunctioned before the
campfire wasn't slated to be part of the
project PG&E later acknowledged in
federal court it had long known that its
high voltage lines could fail and
trigger fires but said that such fires
have historically been relatively rare
I think the utilities in California
recognize that they're operating in a
different world today and that if they
caused fires they won't have a business
in December 2019 state investigators
found a dozen violations the utility had
committed in maintaining its
transmission lines in towers PG&E
acknowledges it still has work to do
since the campfire it has inspected all
its towers lines in substations it
identified 1,200 immediate safety risks
and another 10,000 less urgent repairs
and is making fixes it is also committed
to sharing the results of its
inspections with state regulators and
the public PG&E has also permanently
retired the caribou Palermo line well I
think in the long run all of the
utilities need to harden their grid in
the short run and maybe even the medium
term PG&E is also going to be turning
off the power
since 2018 PG&E has initiated several
weather-related power shut offs to
prevent its equipment from starting more
fires including one that could power to
nearly 750,000 homes and businesses PG&E
future remains uncertain the utility has
reached a thirteen point five billion
dollar settlement with fire victims but
faces a major hurdle and appeasing the
state of California which has raised the
specter of a public take over if PG&E
doesn't enact certain reforms the
Pacific Gas and Electric is unable to
secure its own fate and future then the
state will prepare itself as backup for
a scenario where we do that job for them
people expect that their power is going
to be on all the time and that the
system will not cause them to be afraid
but that's kind of where we live right
now in Northern California and until
that changes I think there is going to
be pushed for much greater oversight of
a company I think that's a challenging
environment for a utility to operate in
particularly one that's trying to get
out of bankruptcy
you